Die 2. Bundesliga der Männer biegt auf die Zielgeraden ein und das Aufstiegsrennen bleibt weiter extrem eng. Auch der 1. FC Magdeburg und der SC Paderborn mischen immer noch oben mit. Packt einer der Clubs die Sensation? Darüber spreche ich in diesem 2. Liga Schwerpunkt mit Thomas Haufe und Kevin Bublitz. Let's go.
Schon im Programm?
Der Rasenfunk.
Lange ein Fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor.
Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Bivou. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
So, und ihr kennt das Spiel aus den letzten Wochen, bevor ich mich und die Gäste vorstelle, eine wichtige Durchsage, die Kontoumpfstellung. Es gibt eine extrem wichtige Hausbeteiligung zu Beginn. Die Bankverbindung des Rasenfunk hat sich geändert. Das haben die meisten mitbekommen, aber vielleicht ja manche eben noch nicht. Alle registrierten SupporterInnen haben dazu eine Mail erhalten, die kann allerdings im Spam gelandet sein, wie uns zu Ohren gekommen ist. Guckt da also unbedingt nochmal nach, wenn ihr nichts bekommen habt. Wie gesagt, die Bankverbindung des Rasenfunk hat sich geändert. Ihr müsst bitte jetzt eure Daueraufträge ändern. Es bleiben noch ein paar Tage und dann gibt es das alte Konto nicht mehr und dann führt der Dauerauftrag ins Nichts und dem Rasenfunk bleibt weniger Geld. Das wäre natürlich sehr schade. Ein paar weitere Infos und vor allen Dingen natürlich die neue Kontoverbindung, die findet ihr in den Show Notes. So, zur Sendung. Mein Name ist Marc Schwitzki. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese 2. Liga Sendung der Männer des Rasenfunks und ich bin freier Journalist. Ihr könnt mich lesen bei RBB24 und hören beim HerthaBase Podcast oder eben hier im Wechsel mit Eva. Und ich stelle meinen ersten Gast vor. Wir hatten schon mal die Ehre diese Saison. Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast.
Ja, wenn diese Spieler gefühlt schon weg sind, ob das nicht in der aktuellen Situation schmerzt, wenn sie dann nicht den ganzen Fokus haben, weil sie wissen...
Ich glaube, die haben schon den Fokus. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt gerade schwierig, weil während wir gerade sprechen, hat der SCP ja gerade begangen, gegeben, dass der Trainer den Verein verlassen wird im Sommer. Ist jetzt gerade offiziell gepostet worden und per Pressemitteilung versendet worden.
Guck mal, ist das nicht schön. Kein Podcast-Tuch. Wir können gleich live brühwarm drüber reden.
Absolut. Also wir haben vor der Sendung, um die Leute hier alle zu informieren, haben noch darüber gesprochen, weil ich habe schon ein paar Vögel zwitschern heute tagsüber. Und wir haben überlegt, wie wir das jetzt machen können, weil es halt nicht offiziell war. Und jetzt ist es aber offiziell. Das heißt, man geht da wirklich schmerzfrei den Weg, dass der Trainer auch geht. Das war für mich auch klar. Das ist wenig überraschend für mich. Wie ich aber aus der Mannschaft so gehört habe, war das für nicht alle Spieler so klar. Und da schließt jetzt deine Frage den Kreis zu deiner Frage. Wird es tatsächlich interessant, ob die Mannschaft das so umwandelt, dass sie daraus jetzt einen Push nochmal kriegt, um zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt zusammen das Ding schaffen, und dann haben wir was erreicht. Oder ob das jetzt eher so ist, oh nee, wenn der Trainer jetzt geht, gucke ich mir auch schon mal um, wo ich hingehe. Ich schätze ein, dass es nicht für den Aufstieg reichen wird.
Ja, bevor wir zu einem… Genau, also gut, da hast du es mir eigentlich quasi vorweg genommen. Wenn wir da auf das Restprogramm nämlich schauen, auch das ist ja jetzt gar nicht mal so einfach. Also Nürnberg, Elbersberg, Schalke, dann das Magdeburg-Spiel und dann KSC. Also Schalke, KSC ist dieselbe Nummer, wie wir vorhin drüber geredet haben. Für die wird es um nichts mehr gehen zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das kann natürlich dankbar sein. Aber Nürnberg, Elbersberg und Magdeburg, das dürften ziemlich heiße Spiele werden. Und jetzt mit drei Niederlagen im Rücken. Du hast gesagt, die Leistungen haben gestimmt. Aber es ist ja oftmals dann so, dass die Leistungen sich irgendwie in den Ergebnissen anpassen, weil dann auch manchmal so ein bisschen der Glaube fehlt, die Spiele noch zu ziehen. Also liegst du gegen Nürnberg wieder hinten aus einer doofen Situation, obwohl du sonst leistungsrechtlich nichts falsch gemacht hast, dann wird es ja wieder schöner.
Vielleicht habe ich auch gerade zuvor schnell geurteilt. Also die Mannschaft hat ja schon immer diesen Spirit. Nicht umsonst sind wir die Mannschaft mit den meisten Toren in der letzten Viertelstunde. Ich glaube, es sind wir. Oder der HSV ist es, einer von beiden. Und das war auch gegen Düsseldorf so. Hätten wir noch 10 Minuten mehr gehabt, hätten wir es, glaube ich, sogar noch gedreht in Unterzahl. Die hat den absoluten Spirit und ich spüre da auch den Willen, dass sie das schaffen wollen. Sie scheitern einfach an sich selbst teilweise. An den Erwartungshaltungen, an dem sie überhastet agieren und dann diese Flüchtigkeitsfehler begehen. Ich glaube, sie haben absolut das Potenzial, auch in diesen Spielen zu bestehen. In Nürnberg ist jetzt auch nicht unser liebster Gegner, aber das sehe ich schon realistisch. Elversberg ist hart. Also Elversberg ist sehr, sehr hart. Die haben ja in Anführungsstrichen gar nichts zu verlieren. Das sagt man immer so leicht. Die haben natürlich auch Druck irgendwo, aber eigentlich von den Kandidaten, die gerade da oben drin sind, sind es quasi die, wo es keiner gedacht hätte. Magdeburg, so haben wir ja schon gesagt, schwierig. Und Schalke, die haben wir auch noch nicht so viele Punkte geholt in der Fans-Historie. Also, weiß ich nicht. Es gäb leichtere Programme, aber eigentlich ist es auch immer gut, weil wenn wir leichte Gegner haben, patzen wir auch oft. Also, ich glaube, die Mannschaft braucht sich gar nicht verstecken. Vom Können her, von der Spielanlage her, können die alle die Spiele gewinnen. Aber, ja, wie du sagst, klar, wenn man irgendwann das Vierte verliert oder so, dann ist natürlich auch der Abstand irgendwann zu groß. Aber es sind zwei Punkte nur, ne?
Ja, voll. Aber geht es nach Lukas Kwasniok, hat man dann am letzten Spieltag im Wildpark ein Finale, in dem er für ihn natürlich… Und es wird dann auch sein Finale, wie wir jetzt dann offiziell besprechen können.
Und er kommt ja auch aus der Gegend. Er kommt ja auch noch. Da hat er beim Cast hier auch schon gearbeitet. Also, das wäre für ihn natürlich dreifach toll.
In den letzten Wochen, ja, fast Monaten, muss man sagen, verging er gefühlt keinen Tag ohne neues Gerücht zu seiner Zukunft. Jetzt ist es dann eben spruchreif. Er hat auf der einen Seite natürlich auch immer wieder ein Feuer ausgestrahlt, weil ich glaube, ohne Feuer gibt es auch kein Lukas Kwasniok. Und gleichzeitig immer wieder gehadert, auch öffentlich mit den limitierten Möglichkeiten des SCP. Und dass man da nicht über eine gewisse Schwelle kommt und man immer im Optimum kratzt, aber das Optimum halt limitiert ist. Wie blickst du denn jetzt auf seine Amtszeit dann zurück, sportlich wie menschlich?
Er ist ja ein streitbarer Mensch. Je nachdem, was für Ansichten man so hat im Leben, wie man so durchs Leben geht, weiß jetzt wahrscheinlich auch jeder, worauf ich anspiele. Also sei es die Impfnummer, sei es sein Ausflug nach Mallorca oder halt eben die öffentliche Deklassierung seiner Keeper oder überhaupt der ganzen Mannschaft. Da kann man immer von halten, was man möchte. Da soll sich jeder bitte sein eigenes Bild auch zu bilden und auch seine Meinung. Trotz alledem hat er es immer geschafft, im Verein zu bleiben. Also ich glaube, jeder hat immer wieder gedacht, also spätestens nach der Mallorca-Nummer, dass dann jetzt auf Schicht im Schacht ist. Dem war aber nicht so. Der Verein hat ihm echt immer den Rücken gestärkt. Und das hat er, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch ohne, dass das irgendwie nur so herausgesagt hat, dem Verein, glaube ich, bis heute sehr dankbar. Oder ist dem Verein sehr dankbar und hat den Verein wirklich, glaube ich, auch lieben gelernt. Das sagen Menschen ja oft auch in der Euphorie so, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass der seine Mannschaft sehr, sehr gern hat und sehr, sehr gern mit der arbeitet. Und das im Dezember war einfach eine Frustnummer. Also wenn man so ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen weiß, dass im Jahr, als der VfB Stuttgart, bevor die Hoeneß geholt haben, eigentlich Wohlgemut ihn haben wollte, der SCP ihn nicht freigegeben hat, bevor der HSV Steffen Baumgart geholt hatte, wollten sie ihn auch haben, hat der SCP ihn nicht freigegeben. Dann hat er seinen Vertrag verlängert und, wie man so hört, hat er dann auch seine Ausstiegsklausel mitverkauft. Das heißt, er hat auch ganz gut wahrscheinlich was für bekommen. Und dann wollte er HSV ihn jetzt wieder haben. Klimaldarmen hat Lukas Kwasniok hier so 25.000 bis 30.000 verdient pro Monat, würde ich schätzen. Und der HSV hat ihm halt 120.000 ungefähr angeboten. Und wenn man dann natürlich überlegt, wo Lukas Kwasniok herkommt, auch nicht aus einem superreichen Elternhaus und es ihm auch nicht alles in den Schoß gefallen hat, hat wirklich viel gearbeitet dafür, dass er da ist, wo er jetzt ist. Hat auch viele Jobs gemacht, war als er beim KSC oder wo es war, neben da noch Dachdecker und so weiter. Also hat, ne, es ihm ist nicht alles zugefallen. Dann kann man es aus der Sicht natürlich vielleicht auch verstehen, dass ihn das persönlich natürlich fertig gemacht hat, weil das natürlich, da hat das große Geld gewunken. Das war quasi die Absicherung für weitere Lebensjahre. Sportlich gesehen war es natürlich schwierig, sag ich mal. Du stehst Ende November auf Platz 1 der 2. Liga und verlierst dann im Dezember alles. Und hast einen Trainer, der noch draufhaut und drauftritt und quasi öffentlich die Mannschaft, ja, demontiert vielleicht nicht, aber zumindest Teile der Mannschaft, wie gesagt, die beiden Keeper. Ich habe Respekt vor Schubert, dass er noch im Verein geblieben ist, sag ich mal so. Die Picker war hart.
Die war hart.
Ja, also das war schon krass. Wie blicke ich aber insgesamt zurück? Ein Top-Trainer, also vom Können her, ist für mich der beste Trainer der 2. Liga, was das In-Game-Coaching angeht. In der 1. Liga kann ich es nicht vergleichen, weil ich das zu sehen zu wenig verfolge. In der 2. Liga ist es der Trainer, der am besten in meiner Ansicht nach im Spiel, während des Spiels auf Situationen reagiert hat, in dieser und auch in den letzten Jahren. Er hat ein gutes Verständnis auf, wie man eine Mannschaft mitnehmen kann und halt auch einen großen Ehrgeiz. Und den hat er in die Mannschaft reingebracht. Er hat jetzt wirklich auch mit Ruhe 3 bis 4 Jahre gearbeitet und sich nicht beirren lassen, von einem Platz 7 oder von einem Platz 8 oder sowas, sondern dann sukzessive. Auch der Verein muss mir auch einen Lob zollen. Also waren zufrieden, haben dann auch mal tief gestapelt. Ja, wir wollen uns jeden so einen Platz verbessern und solche Sachen. Ja, und hat einfach ein Händchen, auch junge Spieler zu integrieren. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das bei ihm dann für den großen Wurf reicht. Aber ich glaube schon, dass er ein Bundesligatrainer sein kann. Er ist der erste Bundesliga-Major. Ein enormes Potenzial und der Verein, das muss man ja auch mal sagen, in solche Fußstaffen zu treten, die Steffen Baumgart hier hinterlassen hat.
Das muss man sagen.
Dann auch es zu schaffen, hier vier Jahre Trainer zu bleiben, ist halt auch krass. Also SCP hat in den letzten, wann ist Baumgart gekommen? 2014, 2015?
Ende 2013, 2014, 14, 15. Nee, stimmt nicht. Es war später. Wir sind aufgestiegen vor der Saison 2017, 2018 sind wir aufgestiegen und wir sind dann der Bundesliga hochmarschiert.
Wir hatten auf jeden Fall zwei Trainer in den letzten 8-10 Jahren. Krass, also SC Freiburg hat sowas. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Thomas…
In den Baumdaten kam 2017.
2017, siehst du, Thomas weiß das besser als ich.
Ich sag, ey, Podcast-Beinschaft, mal gucken, wie viel Beweis und Beweis.
Aber irre, selbst das von 2017 bis 2025 zwei Trainer, das ist schon… Und das spricht für Lukas Kwasniok definitiv, also sportlich, dass ich da wenig an drunten rankomme. Das, was er noch lernen muss, ist einfach in bestimmten Situationen, die Mannschaft nicht so schwach zu reden. Das ist über die Jahre immer wieder ein Problem gewesen, wenn man oben stand, dann haben er es und auch Benny Weber, jetzt der sportliche Vorstand, immer wieder gerne mal gemacht, dass man gesagt hat, ja, also das ist gerade nicht das, was die Mannschaft… Also das ist gerade nicht unser Niveau da oben. Also das ist nicht unser Können, unser Potential ist tiefer. Unsere Mannschaft ist überperformed. Das muss man die Füße stillhalten. Und immer dann kam auch der Knick. Das ist total krass. Immer wenn man das zu gemacht hat, es war im November, Ende November auch, als man auf Platz 1 stand, dann, ach nee, ach komm, hör mir auf. Frag mich nochmal nach dem 35. Spiel, oder irgendwie so. Ja, ja, genau. Also am besten nächste Saison erst fragen. Und ja, das ist noch so ein Ding. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch echt schwierig, in so einer Situation zu arbeiten, wo du weißt, der Verein hat keine Kohle für Spieler, die schon mal was erlebt haben, irgendwo. Und du musst halt immer wieder anfangen von vorne quasi. Du verlierst einen Schallenberg, du verlierst einen Justwahn, du verlierst einen, äh, hier, wie heißt er, mit M, der nach Freiburg gegangen ist. Guck mal, Muslia, so. Ja, und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt, wenn wir jetzt mal drüber gucken, welche Spieler jetzt gehen werden, sind das meine Ansicht nach Zehnther, Anser, Obermeier, Brackelmann, Castaneda. Und habe ich noch einen vergessen.
Engels vielleicht.
Engels, ja, der war jetzt zu sehr verletzt, das wird noch dauern. Das ist einfach, ja, und dann ist ja quasi die ganze, also die halbe Startelfeck, ne. Und das frustriert dich als Trainer natürlich, das war das, was er, glaube ich, meinte. Der arbeitet so, hat mit der Mannschaft zusammen und scheitert immer dann kurz vor knapp. Und da hat er, der will jetzt einfach was anderes sehen. Soll er auch machen, ist auch gut. Hier wäre über den Sommer auch gar kein, also das hat er sich im Winter kaputt gehauen, die Scherben gehauen, das wäre über den Sommer nicht gegangen. Also mit dem Aufstieg vielleicht noch, ja, okay. Aber dafür hat er jetzt auch einfach zu viele Offerten. Der wird jetzt gefühlt bei jedem Verein gehandelt.
Aber ich glaube, das wird beim SCP, das ist so der Eindruck, den ich hier aus der Entfernung habe, ich glaube seit Krösche hat man in Paderbornen Strukturen aufgebaut, wo man es geschafft hat, so ein Stück weit personenunabhängig zu werden. Wenn man überlegt, was da in den letzten Jahren Krösche weg, Wohlgemut weg, Baumgott weg und das war ja immer so, dass Paderbornen es geschafft hat, trotzdem in ihrer Arbeit weiter konstant zu bleiben, weiter auch bei sich zu bleiben und da finde ich, das ist etwas, das hat man uns in Magdeburg in meiner Meinung noch voraus, dass man es geschafft hat, ein Stück weit personenunabhängig zu sein. Das ist ein ganz großes Pfund in der 2. Liga, dass du eben nicht davon abhängig bist, dass da ein Trainer kommt, von dem machst du dich wieder abhängig, dass der seine Ideen reinbringt, dann schmeißt du den auch von raus, dann stehst du wieder bei Null. Ich glaube, das ist ein Punkt, da hat Paderbornen einigen 2. Ligisten voraus, dass man sagen kann, die sind personenunabhängig, die können da hinsetzen, wen sie wollen, das funktioniert.
Ein paar Erstligisten, ja. Das ist tatsächlich so, das war das, was ich vorhin meinte. Als Kwasniok, als Kwasniok ist, also Markus Kwasniok ist hier, glaube ich, fast jeder dankbar in Paderborn, weil der ist wirklich, also das wirklichen, es klingt jetzt sehr hochtram, das Mastermind, was das angeht. Der hat diesen Verein einfach gelesen, der weiß, wie der Verein funktioniert. Der wusste ganz genau aus seiner Karriere heraus, aus seinem Studium, was er nebenbei hatte, aus seinen Erfahrungen in Leverkusen, was zu tun muss, damit das bei so einem Verein überhaupt irgendwie mit Profi-Fußball funktionieren kann. Und das haben nicht viele andere Feinde. Wenn du siehst, was Krösche jetzt aus Spielern, also was der in Frankfurt für Ablösen erzielt mit Spielern, das ist ja unfassbar.
Und gleichzeitig performt die Mannschaft trotzdem weiter durch. Also nicht so, dass du die 100 Millionen einnimmst und plötzlich bist du elfter, sondern die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder Champions League spielen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn die jetzt Elias Ansa tatsächlich holen sollten. Wo der Weg so hinführt von ihm.
Ich würde auch gelesen, Union Berlin soll auch dran sein. Das sind ja noch zwei verschiedene Welten. Mal gucken, wie das ausgeht. Du hast schon ein bisschen darüber geredet. Du glaubst, dass die Mannschaft schon im Sommer ein Stück weit auseinanderfallen könnte oder wird. Bei einem ausbleibenden Aufstieg ja umso mehr wahrscheinlich, weil diese Spieler dann noch mehr das Bedürfnis haben werden, was anderes zu sehen. Aber auch wenn du den Abgesang schon ein bisschen gestartet hast, der Aufstieg ist ja immer noch drin.
Absolut.
Solange Lukas Kwasniok da ist, glaube ich, wird er auch noch dem Höchsten streben, weil das sieht ja im Portfolio nicht so ganz verkehrt aus, mit Paderborn das dann auch geschafft zu haben.
Das stimmt.
Glaubst du denn, dass Paderborn dieses Mal besser absteigen könnte als 14, 15 und 19, 20, als man dann jeweils wieder als 18. runtergegangen ist? Oder ist das einfach die Beste Realität? Du gehst hoch, nimmst wieder was, schürfst ein bisschen was ab, wirtschaftlich und gehst wieder runter.
Ja, da ist der Verein noch nicht. Der Verein hat sich auf jeden Fall weiterentwickelt, hat deutlich mehr Potenziale geschaffen. Aber mir fehlt da die Fantasie. Die Fantasie fehlt mir nicht, aber mir fehlt der realistische, nachhaltige Beweis, dass das klappen könnte. Weil wir haben, glaube ich, 20 oder irgendwas Millionen zur Verfügung. Und wenn es dann die 1. Liga ist, dann sind es vielleicht 35 maximal. Ja, sorry. Da gewinnst du keinen Blumentopf in der 1. Bundesliga. Da kann wieder auf Euphorie-Welle irgendwie, wenn die Mannschaft zusammenbleiben würde, im Fall des Aufstiegs könnte auf der Euphorie-Welle irgendwie geritten werden. Aber du hast ja dann auch einen neuen Trainer. Ja, so dann glaube ich nicht. Also, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Weiß nicht, wie.
Das wäre natürlich irgendwie fast undankbar als neuer Trainer, dass dann schon klar, du dürftest im Bundesliga-Feind trainieren.
Naja, klar.
So etwas ist nie undankbar, aber gleichzeitig, was willst du da gewinnen? Aber ja, das sind Sorgen für die Zukunft. Ich glaube, an der Stelle machen wir die Nummer dann zu. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir berühmt waren, dann noch über die Kwasniok-Nummer reden konnten und da jetzt nicht so im theoretischen Raum bleiben mussten. Das hilft natürlich total. Dementsprechend zünde ich jetzt schon mal das Intro ab und bedanke mich an der Stelle. Vielen lieben Dank, Thomas Haufe, für deine Zeit nur der FCM-Podcast. Hört rein. Danke. Und zum anderen Kevin Bublitz vom Padercast. Wie immer eine Freude. Dieses Mal durfte ich die Freude teilen. Hat großen Spaß gemacht. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen lieben Dank. Bis dann.
So, dann wie gesagt, Supporters Club und Kontoumständungen nicht vergessen. Wichtig, wichtig.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.